petter monsieur gérard manuel merci
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues
monsieur le premier ministre il ya tout
juste un an le monde el ghiwane étaient
massivement dans la rue le gouvernement
avait promis de soutenir et agriculteurs
le résultat aujourd'hui est
particulièrement édifiant le journal les
échos rappelait ce matin que
l'agriculture est la seule activité
économique où les défaillances
d'entreprises ne sont pas gravés en 2016
avec une hausse de 4%
tous les secteurs sont touchés de la
filière fruits et légumes aux filières
viande en passant par des céréales
revenus en forte baisse défaillances
d'entreprises en forte hausse
c'est le bilan de votre action au bout
de cinq ans de pouvoir
bien sûr la météo du printemps 2016 n'a
pas été favorable mais n'explique pas
que le lait soit payé 320 euros la tonne
en moyenne en france c'est-à-dire 20% de
moins qu'aux pays bas
elle n'explique pas dans un monde
globalisé les agriculteurs français sont
les seuls à être assommés par autant de
charges et de réglementation on
n'explique pas non plus que les
agriculteurs allemands connaissent des
chars nettement inférieur au nôtre notre
pays champion de la sueur transposition
et ses agriculteurs paient aujourd'hui
les joies politique de votre
gouvernement
rappelez vous il ya encore quelques
années la france était le deuxième pays
exportateur de produits agricoles au
monde
aujourd'hui la france a rétrogradé à la
5e place et sur le plan humain
cela se traduit par de nombreux drames
de faillite nombreuses des agriculteurs
surendettés qui se tourne
une ultime fois vers les banques qui se
montrent de plus en plus réticente et
trouvant la seule réponse est de mettre
la clé sous la porte
pour cette seule année 2010 est on
prévoit encore vingt mille fermeture
d'exploitations agricoles
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur
mise d'art et culture devant cette
situation à laquelle vous n'avez pas
répondu
quelles sont les mesures que vous
entendez prendre pour soutenir ses
agriculteurs
mais si la parole est à monsieur
stéphane le foll mini l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt vision
monsieur le député vous avez fait une
liste qui était bien longue
divisez bien sûr à mettre la
responsabilité sur le ministre gariglio
sur le gouvernement
je vous rappellerai simplement les
crises que nous avons et avaient
traversé vous avez parlé de la crise du
lait
on peut tout à fait en discuter décision
suppression des quotas laitiers en 2008
mise en place d'un processus qui conduit
à une surproduction et cette
surproduction elle commence 2013 2014 on
redresse la situation 2014 elle
s'aggrave en 2015 elle se redresse
aujourd'hui après une action de la
france et de ministre de l'agriculture
jeudi quand même au passage qui a
consisté à remettre de la régulation
là où il y en avait plus donc monsieur
le député sur ce point là déjà
chacun doit assumer ses responsabilités
deuxièmement vous évoquez à cette ombre
de crise louis crise sanitaire grippe
aviaire deux ans de suite
vous avez évoqué la crise des céréales
prix des céréales à l'échelle mondiale
chicago inondations l'an dernier qui met
en cause 30% de la production des
céréales
c'est une responsabilité c'est de venir
en aide mais jusqu'ici je ne suis pas
responsable est tant mieux d'ailleurs du
temps qu'il fait en france sur la fc o
et la crise bovine fièvre catarrhale
ovine qu'on connaît et qui nous a
handicapés nous avons lui des
difficultés crise porcine en bretagne
qui aujourd'hui nous sortons de cette
crise avec des prix qui se sont
redressés à chaque fois nous sommes
venus avec le plan de soutien à
l'élevage avec le plan de consolidation
apporter des aides mais qui ne compense
pas j'en ai parfaitement conscience
le niveau de la baie le privé monsieur
le député dans ces conditions ne venez
pas porter une charge aussi lourde quand
chacun et ceux qui ont pris des
décisions il ya dix ans ont une part de
la responsabilité de la situation
d'aujourd'hui
chacun doit dans ce domaine là resté
avec un peu de rationalité et
d'objectivité et le tas et le
gouvernement a été à chaque fois
présents pour apporter des solutions aux
agriculteurs et quant aux chiffres de ce
matin qui sont sortis par une société
altares les comparaisons sur les
faillites qui sont faites par rapport à
une année précédente
et j'ai pas bien compris quelle était la
référence mais c'est irait à leur
représentation à part